[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta edición especial
del debate de france 24 soy santiago
lópez gonzález el 2020 será recordado
por obvias razones por la pandemia de
kobe 19 y las múltiples consecuencias
que trajo para la humanidad este hecho
que nos tomó prácticamente por sorpresa
en muchos sentidos pero esto no impidió
que el acontecer siguiera su curso las
noticias y también los hechos destacados
siguieron teniendo lugar pese a que
estábamos muy atentos al desarrollo de
la pandemia en especial en este especial
del debate hablaremos de esos otros
hechos que también fueron noticia a lo
largo del año en colombia hemos hecho
precisamente una selección de cinco
temas que se los presento a continuación
esta es nuestra agenda para este
programa especial hablaremos de los
asesinatos de los líderes sociales y las
masacres también de la brutalidad
policial el caso del expresidente álvaro
uribe los avances en la implementación
del acuerdo de paz y finalmente el paso
del huracán yo está que afecto
el archipiélago de san andrés
providencia y santa catalina
y para analizar y para conversar sobre
esta agenda de temas hemos invitado a
adriana otálora ella es profesora de la
universidad de la salle en la ciudad de
bogotá en colombia es también
coordinadora de la línea de ciudadanía
ética y política del doctorado de
estudios de desarrollo y territorio
también nos acompaña desde la capital
colombiana sergio guarín él es director
ejecutivo de reconciliación colombia y
también se une a este diálogo desde
bogotá la capital colombiana les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar todas
sus preguntas y sus comentarios en las
redes sociales se los recuerdo estamos
en facebook y también los encuentran
en instagram y en twitter como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 pues comenzamos y quiero entonces
que marquemos el primer tema de la
agenda que es el asesinato de los
líderes sociales y las masacres que ha
habido en colombia a lo largo de este
2020 de acuerdo a cifras del instituto
de estudios de para el desarrollo y la
paz
251 asesinatos de líderes sociales y
defensores de los derechos humanos han
tenido lugar en colombia 84 casos en el
cauca en el sur occidente del país y 26
en antioquia que es en el occidente de
colombia cada semana prácticamente en el
2020 asesinaron a seis defensores de
defensores de derechos humanos como ya
lo decíamos las masacres pues también
las cifras son son bastante altas cerca
de 309 personas han muerto en 77
masacres diferentes incluso en algunas
de ellas hubo varios menores de edad el
problema acá es que esto queda en la
impunidad no hay un desarrollo en las
investigaciones judiciales en torno a
estos hechos y comienzo preguntándole
adriana otálora nuestra invitada cuál es
el balance que usted hace sobre este
tema porque en colombia se están viendo
este tipo de masacres cuando se ha
firmado un acuerdo de paz con la ex
guerrilla de las farc y supuestamente el
país daba unos pasos hacia una
reconciliación social
bueno muchas gracias santiago bueno
cuando uno firma un acuerdo de paz esté
solamente el principio de un proceso que
nosotros no hemos cumplido a cabalidad
en colombia
y la dejación de las armas deja un
espacio de poder vacío el cual comienza
a ser llenado por distintos grupos en
distintos dinámicas y momentos pues en
el país y si el estado no tiene una
presencia una institucionalidad
suficiente no solamente mediante la
fuerza sino toda la institucionalidad
del estado comienzan a surgir todo este
tipo de fenómenos que en parte además
son alimentados por fenómenos como el
narcotráfico también obviamente aunado
por esa ausencia de poder en los
territorios y por conflictos
socioambientales los líderes que
dolorosamente han sido asesinados en
nuestro país no únicamente son
defensores de derechos humanos sino
también defensores de los derechos de la
naturaleza y de la justicia
intergeneracional que esperaríamos tener
con las futuras generaciones esto
implica un cambio de modelo que
desafortunadamente como país no hemos
sabido leer interpretar ni establecer
diálogos que nos permitan comenzar a
construir país
desde la comunidad y no únicamente desde
el control de los territorios a través
de la fuerza eso implica que niños y
niñas están siendo también asesinados no
únicamente como amenaza sino ya como
resultado de una violencia que no no
tiene un objetivo específico sino esa el
llenar los espacios de poder y sergio
guarín su opinión sobre este tema que
desconcierta a la comunidad
internacional ver cómo colombia está
volviendo a presenciar estos actos de
masacres y de asesinatos de líderes
sociales que pensaba la comunidad
internacional que estaban comenzando a
dejarse atrás pero este 2020 las cifras
muestran que están repuntando
gracias santiago por la invitación un
saludo especial adriana yo creo que
estas dos con las que estamos arrancando
este debate son las peores noticias del
año 2020 porque muestran de manera muy
clara que colombia tiene todavía unas
estructuras ilegales armadas que están
en condiciones de ejercer coacción
contra la población en las regiones más
vulnerables del país el tema del
asesinato de los líderes sociales es
especialmente grave no sólo porque son
violaciones flagrantes a los derechos
humanos y al derecho internacional
humanitario sino porque cada vida de un
líder o una lideresa que se pierde es
una oportunidad de transformación que se
pierde también
y en esos casos hay dos móviles que se
han identificado claramente uno es la
motivación política es decir que estas
personas eran o estaban abanderando
causas que eran incómodas para actores
armados ilegales y por lado está la
causa relacionada con las economías
criminales en esos casos como por
ejemplo en el caso de la sustitución de
los cultivos de uso ilícito es claro que
varios de estos líderes habían venido
apoyando los programas de sustitución y
se estaban oponiendo a los procesos de
resiembra el hecho de que ellos mueran
lo que hace es amedrentar a la población
y mostrarle a la población que esas
esperanzas de cambio son esperanzas
gravemente amenazadas en el caso de las
masacres lo terrible de esa situación es
que muestra la capacidad que tienen
algunas estructuras organizadas para
ejercer acciones de mucha presión
acciones de mucho dolor contra población
que está inerme y eso frente a una
falta de reacción eficaz por parte de la
fuerza pública una cosa que es
importante y con eso finalizó es que
tanto en el caso de los líderes como de
las masacres tenemos procesos de
esclarecimiento bastante avanzados y las
cifras que tiene la fiscalía a propósito
de esos esclarecimiento son son una
buena noticia dentro de este panorama
sombrío pero lo que muestra es que nos
está faltando mucha capacidad de
anticipación si bien estamos mejorando
la capacidad de reacción y una de las
críticas que le han hecho al gobierno
del presidente de educa es precisamente
que no hay un sistema de alertas
tempranas o si lo hay la capacidad de
reacción ante este tipo de hechos en
particular las masacres tienen poca
capacidad de reacción las fuerzas
militares para ir a proteger allí la
población civil
sigo con usted sergio voy a hacer la
ronda la inversa adriana para luego
tocar con usted otro tema sobre la
presencia del estado en zonas rurales
pero
en el sergio en particular el gobierno
colombiano fue muy criticado por
diferentes sectores allí en colombia por
calificar estas masacres como asesinatos
selectivos que busca el gobierno
cambiando la terminología bajando un
poco tal vez la importancia de los
hechos o quería de pronto lavarse un
poco las manos de la responsabilidad o
simplemente cambiándolo la terminología
el estado puede acceder a hacer una
reparación más adelante en otros
términos cuál es el concepto ahí
bueno para mí es muy difícil valorar las
motivaciones que tenía el gobierno al
cambiar la terminología yo estimo que
una cosa que era importante para la
actual administración era mostrar que
los indicadores principales de seguridad
no se estaban deteriorando porque en
cierta manera al elegir al presidente
eduqué como a nuestro presidente actual
estabamos optando digamos la ciudadanía
colombiana está adoptando por un modelo
que pretendía garantizar la seguridad y
que veía unas amenazas de seguridad y
quería tomar acciones eficaces en contra
de ellas creo que reconocer las masacres
en su concepto completo implicaba
admitir también que ese tema que era el
tema de la seguridad que era una de las
banderas principales de lo que es ahora
el partido de gobierno pues estaba
deteriorándose de todas maneras creo que
eso fue una equivocación y creo que el
gobierno muy rápidamente echó para atrás
en esa equivocación
y que hoy en día no nos queda más que
reconocer que el tema de masacre se está
empeorando yo creo que una de las cosas
que tenemos que reconocer todos
colombianos y las colombianas es que hay
unas zonas del país especialmente
algunas de las zonas del llamado
posconflicto que están viviendo una un
agravamiento de las condiciones de
seguridad que es muy muy preocupante no
al punto de llevarnos a la época en la
que estaba en la confrontación entre
guerrilla y paramilitarismo pero sí en
una situación muy deteriorada con
respecto a los avances que se habían
logrado posterior a la negociación esa
es precisamente la pregunta que le tengo
adriana porque usted lo mencionaba en su
primera intervención y es esa falta de
la presencia del estado que justamente
es uno de los puntos pactados en esa en
ese acuerdo de paz con la ex guerrilla
de las farc uno de los puntos era
precisamente garantizar la educación en
zonas rurales o en zonas que fueron
sometidas a lo largo de las últimas
décadas a este conflicto armado que
estaban aisladas por falta de caminos de
infraestructura de presencia del estado
en líneas generales porque le es tan
difícil al estado colombiano garantizar
su presencia en todos los rincones del
país
bueno ahí hay varios elementos entre
otros pues el abandono que durante toda
nuestra historia hemos tenido desde el
sector rural también esta idea falsa de
que el progreso en una idea pues lineal
de modernidad es lo que deberíamos
llevar de las ciudades al campo y que
termina expulsando no únicamente por la
violencia sino por la falta de
oportunidades a jóvenes del campo en las
ciudades es decir nosotros en nuestra
planeación del desarrollo continuamos
pensando desde lo urbano y no
reconociendo las características y las
riquezas de cada una de las comunidades
rurales tendemos a taparnos los ojos a
disminuir el valor de nuestra población
rural y a buscar soluciones sin
incluirlos a ellos y en esa medida
cualquier estrategia cualquier política
pública que se
y formulen nuestro país no va a tener
suficiente asidero en la vida real ni
continuidad como para lograr transformar
la realidad social la falta de
institucionalidad en nuestras regiones
también hace parte de esa idea de
excesivo centralismo en donde únicamente
se gobierna para los centros urbanos y
no para las realidades rurales donde no
hay infraestructura donde en efecto como
como tú lo mencionabas las escuelas
rurales están en unas condiciones tanto
de acceso como de calidad incluso de
infraestructura en las mismas escuelas
que dificulta que los maestros y
maestras puedan ofrecer un servicio
adecuado a los niños a las niñas y
participar en algo que también es muy
importante en la construcción de paz y
es en una educación para la paz en el
poder pensar nos como una sola comunidad
como ciudadanos activos de alguna manera
ese taparnos los ojos frente a nuestros
ciudadanos y ciudadanas rurales ha hecho
que dejemos de reconocerlos como parte
de nuestro país
en efecto tengamos unos territorios casi
que abandonados buena parte de la
extensión geográfica del país no cuenta
con esa institucionalidad y además con
un desmedro de recursos donde los
funcionarios públicos en estos
territorios tienen que cumplir varias
funciones a la vez luego no hay una
posibilidad de intervenir técnicamente
en los en el territorio rural
adriana continuó con usted pero pasamos
a otro punto de la agenda porque tengo
que avanzar tengo cinco puntos del
programa es corto y es la controversia
que ha generalizada que ha generado allí
en colombia algunos hechos puntuales de
la acción de la forma en que han actuado
integrantes de la policía nacional en
algunas manifestaciones en la noche del
8 al 9 de septiembre falleció el abogado
javier ordóñez a manos de la policía
después de haber recibido diez descargas
con pistolas eléctricas un hecho similar
sucedió un año anterior en otras
manifestaciones y ha sido muy criticada
la institución de la policía como tal
por parte de la sociedad colombiana
dejo estos hechos como se encuentra la
relación entre ciudadanía y policía como
institución y el gobierno
aún se encuentra bastante fracturada es
una relación de confianza que debe
ganarse con evidencia con hechos y de
alguna manera también con interacción
entre los policías y los ciudadanos
en nuestro país ha existido siempre
cierta desconfianza frente a la policía
por parte de la mayoría de ciudadanos y
ciudadanas más que frente al ejército
parte de nuestro conflicto hizo que
tuviéramos que confiar mucho más en esas
fuerzas militares pero que esa esa
violencia que comienza a pulular en todo
el país se viera restringido de una
manera tajante fuerte y en algunas
ocasiones brutal en la por la policía en
las ciudades la policía es una fuerza
civil es una fuerza que debe generar
confianza y seguridad y convivencia al
interior de las ciudades en este momento
de pandemia va a ser aún más difícil
hacer eso no únicamente por capacidad de
la misma fuerza policial sino porque hay
una altísima desconfianza que no es
solamente de estos años sino de toda esa
herencia que tenemos en nuestra historia
del conflicto
que no se han tomado acciones concretas
que permitan que los ciudadanos podamos
ver a los policías alguien a quien
recurrir en caso de emergencia pedir
ayuda o construir conjuntamente claro
que hay casos pero continúan siendo
casos muy puntuales así como los de la
brutalidad y no hay acciones aún
concretas que nos permitan tener una
mayor confianza en general sergio y
teniendo claro entonces esta fractura
que menciona adriana entre la sociedad y
la institución de la policía en este
país qué futuro puede tener entonces en
mejorar esta relación qué medidas está
tomando el gobierno o los gobiernos
locales de las diferentes alcaldías o
gobernaciones para mejorar esa esa
relación porque en un país que tiene
unos altos índices de violencia como los
que tiene colombia que ya los
mencionamos con masacres y violencia
dentro de las ciudades y asesinatos de
líderes sociales la fuerza pública es
fundamental y es fundamental que los
ciudadanos confíen en esta fuerza
pública cómo mejorar esa confianza de
acuerdo a lo que se está diciendo allí
desde el gobierno
pues santiago el tema de la desconfianza
de los ciudadanos en la policía es un
tema mundial y los temas de brutalidad
policial lamentablemente también están
en la agenda mundial las políticas
públicas que en general se orientan para
mejorar esa consigue esta confianza
siempre tienen tres tres principales
medidas una es el tema de vigilancia
ciudadana en las acción de las
instituciones en este caso de la acción
de la policía todos el mejoramiento en
los temas de entrenamiento y formación y
tres la transparencia y la rendición de
cuentas que son cosas en las que la
policía colombiana tiene que avanzar
mucho más la última vez que colombia
hizo una reforma policial importante fue
en el año 1993 y después de ese reforma
que fue una reforma histórica y se
llevaron a cabo varias decisiones que
hicieron que la policía colombiana se
volviera un referente muy importante a
nivel internacional sobre todo
latinoamericano en temas de inteligencia
en temas de acciones inter operacionales
en temas de acciones antinarcóticos
estamos en mora de hacer una nueva
reforma una nueva reforma más orientada
hacia el servicio de seguridad ciudadana
de la cercanía de los policías con
respecto a la ciudadanía ahora hay
algunas alcaldías que han asumido este
tema de la policía desde la perspectiva
de una digamos de una discusión política
y me parece que cuando eso ha sucedido
eso no le ha hecho bien a la confianza
ciudadana porque si bien hay que
exigirle a la policía el mejoramiento y
hay que exigirle a la policía la reforma
tampoco está bien utilizar de manera
política la crítica a la policía para
generar digamos un ambiente político en
el sentido que a ciertos candidatos oa
ciertos gobernantes les interesa
entonces yo creo que este es un tema
demasiado sensible como para ponerlo a
la discusión de la política local y creo
que aquí lo que se necesita son reformas
de fondo reformas en estos tres puntos
que acabamos de mencionar y que podrían
llegar a ser exitosas si se ponen en
marcha de manera rap
interesante ese análisis sergio y
continuo con usted para pasar a la
siguiente al siguiente punto de la
agenda y es el caso del ex presidente
álvaro uribe que se convirtió en el
primer ex mandatario de colombia en
rendir una indagatoria que es una
declaración judicial ante la corte
suprema de justicia por una
investigación que hay en su contra por
presunto fraude procesal y compra de
testigos traemos este tema a la agenda
por la importancia que tiene álvaro
uribe para la escena política colombiana
un expresidente que todavía sigue en el
escenario político y sigue siendo una
persona que además genera mucha
polarización dentro de la sociedad
colombiana cuál es su opinión sobre este
tema sergio sobre este caso que va en
marcha pues santiago yo tengo digamos la
opinión de que hay un efecto positivo y
que hay un efecto negativo de esta
situación que ha vivido el ex presidente
el efecto positivo tiene que ver con
esta idea que existe en colombia de que
las instituciones no tocan a los
poderosos yo creo que la investigación
en torno al expresidente uribe y sobre
todo la manera en que está se derivó de
una denuncia una demanda que él mismo
había puesto lo que muestra es que las
instituciones colombianas gozan ser con
con independencia y digamos con una
cierta autonomía que debe ser reconocida
y debe ser validada obviamente aquí no
estoy valorando el resultado de la
investigación sino lo que estoy diciendo
es que este caso lo que muestra es que
parte de nuestra institucionalidad sigue
protegiendo este principio de separación
de poderes y que hay una independencia
en los criterios y eso se vio no solo en
las decisiones de la corte suprema de
justicia sino ya cuando pasó el caso a
la fiscalía las distintas decisiones que
se están tomando y yo creo que eso es
una muy buena noticia porque las
democracias
están basadas en los sistemas de pesos y
contrapesos la mala noticia es que creo
que esta situación en la que se pone en
el ojo del huracán de nuevo la figura
del expresidente agudiza el entorno
polarizador que se viene atizando y se
bautizar de manera muy especial en el
2021 como prólogo de la nueva campaña
presidencial y ese era y ese es un tema
que es nocivo para la democracia
colombiana porque es importante que
colombia después de estos digamos 8 años
del ex presidente uribe sus 8 años del
ex presidente santos y ahora estos 4
años empiece a salir de la discusión de
uribismo y antiuribismo como eje central
de las discusiones de política pública y
creo que el hecho de que el ex
presidente esté en medio de esta
discusión judicial va a hacer que este
tema sea un tema central alrededor del
cual va a gravitar la discusión política
de nuevo y que se mantenga esa esa
polarización que no le hace bien a la
sociedad colombiana adriana su opinión
sobre este tema y sobre cómo empezar a
enmendar esa
la polarización esa división que hay
entre los colombianos entre como lo
decía hacer yo uribistas y antiuribistas
y que el país empiece a dejar esas
páginas de la historia atrás y empieza a
concentrarse en la reconstrucción de
país de nación y de sociedad hacia
futuro
bueno estoy completamente de acuerdo con
sergio hay un elemento positivo que es
esa confianza institucional en que si
tenemos la posibilidad de que haya unos
unas instancias superiores a cualquier
persona creo que ese sería el primer
camino profundizar esa confianza en las
instituciones y quienes la representan
de tal manera que no se reavive esa idea
de la personalización de la política que
tanto daño le ha hecho a todos los
países del mundo y a todas las
democracias
en colombia en este caso creo que ya no
estamos en un punto de polarización sino
de radicalización y que es todavía más
dañino para la democracia un camino es
la construcción de opinión pública a
través de la labor como la que ustedes
hacen de los medios de comunicación de
tal manera que sean temas grandes los
que no se discutan en este espacio y no
la posible judicialización de la
política y posterior personalización en
personajes como álvaro uribe u otros que
en nuestro país tienden a personalizar
la política tomando en sus propias
palabras la voz del pueblo y eso va en
contra de cualquier democracia
necesitamos proyectos conjuntos y de
largo plazo nuestro siguiente punto en
la agenda es la implementación del
acuerdo de paz o un tema muy grande muy
denso para explicar en poco más de cinco
minutos pero adriana cuatro años para
muchos sectores ha habido pocos avances
en esta implementación hay muchas
críticas al gobierno que defiende que si
ha avanzado en su implementación de las
107 leyes que se necesitaban para
meditación completa del acuerdo 66 ya
han sido expedidas cuatro de ellas
solamente a lo largo de estos años del
gobierno de iván duque
porque no avanza este acuerdo de paz tan
rápido como espera la comunidad
internacional y como muchos colombianos
esperaban
en parte por voluntad política pero
teníamos no digamos que como país no se
aprovechó una ventana de oportunidad
para adaptar más agilidad a toda la
reglamentación del acuerdo de paz como
tal en parte por impositiva posibilidad
de llegar efectivamente a los
territorios en parte por esa
polarización de radicalización de la que
a la que me estaba refiriendo que hace
que exista todavía cierto recelo y
desconfianza en las comunidades y en la
medida en que comienza a darse todo el
proceso de implementación del acuerdo
pero que éste tiende a quedarse en los
espacios territoriales en donde están
habitando los reincorporados y no
generar de manera continua permanente
interacciones con la comunidad pues va a
ser aún más difícil lograr avances
efectivos y significativos a la
implementación del acuerdo el acuerdo no
es únicamente digamos que él
la institucionalidad o la legalidad que
se logra estructurar alrededor del mismo
sino que es principalmente la manera
como todos los ciudadanos y ciudadanas
nos sumamos a un proyecto conjunto este
tipo de cosas pues que nos interesan
como país y en ese sentido hay todavía
muchísima desconfianza no ha existido un
mecanismo adecuado para que la gente
logre un proceso de reconciliación que
en eso pues es experto sergio y por otra
parte esa polarización y personalización
de la política hace que comencemos a
pensar en amigos de la paz como amigos
de una una corriente política específica
sin que eso necesariamente sea
equiparable y hay que aclararle a
nuestra audiencia que está fuera de las
fronteras colombianas que este acuerdo
de paz fue firmado con un grupo
guerrillero específico las farc
hoy en día convertida en un partido
político pero hay otros actores armados
y grupos al margen de la ley que hacen
parte de este conflicto que vive
colombia desde hace varias décadas
muchos de estos grupos han empezado a
parar
en los últimos años después de esta
firma de este acuerdo de paz con las
farc es precisamente llenando esos
espacios donde el estado no logró llegar
y que quedaron vacíos una vez las farc
abandonaron estos lugares en la mayoría
de ellos en zonas selváticas en el sur y
en el occidente del país
sergio su opinión sobre la
implementación de este acuerdo de paz y
porque a los colombianos les cuesta
tanto dar ese paso para para la
implementación o al gobierno en sí pues
mira santiago cuando uno lee los
estudios más independientes que se han
hecho sobre el acuerdo de paz y su
implementación y cuando uno mira los
informes de monitoreo lo que uno se da
cuenta es que el acuerdo de paz no va ni
también como dice el gobierno ni tan mal
como dicen los críticos del gobierno lo
que sucede es que este es un acuerdo
tremendamente complejo que tiene
muchísimas decisiones medidas unas de
carácter gubernamental otras de carácter
legislativo otras de diseño
institucional
y que tiene un horizonte de aplicación
en el tiempo larga y yo lo que creo es
que en términos generales tenemos unos
avances que son muy importantes
reconocer el primero y más evidente es
que el acuerdo está sobreviviendo entre
comillas a un gobierno liderado por el
partido político que le hizo la
oposición al acuerdo de paz y el hecho
de que este acuerdo sobreviva este
cuatrenio con ajustes con énfasis con
acentos pero avanzando en la agenda de
implementación es una buenísima noticia
porque eso lo que quiere decir es que no
dependerá de la bandera política del
gobierno que algunas de las cosas claves
pasen lo segundo es que hay temas que
han venido avanzando de manera
sustancial se ha avanzado en el catastro
multipropósito se ha avanzado en la
implementación de los planes de
desarrollo con enfoque territorial se
hizo la desmovilización efectiva de más
de 10.000 personas que estaban en armas
se tomaron algunas decisiones con
respecto a las leyes por ejemplo hoy
tenemos un estatuto de oposición
gracias al acuerdo de paz tenemos nuevas
reglas para hacer oposición política y
esos cambios van a generar efectos
significativos en el mediano y largo
plazo en colombia lo que no quiere decir
que haya muchos temas que todavía están
pendientes como por ejemplo los temas de
democratización del acceso a la tierra
como los temas de protección de los
liderazgos sociales y como los de
ampliación democrática entonces la
impresión que yo tengo es que la
valoración más objetiva de este tema
está un poco mutilada por como lo decía
a adrián ahora por este ambiente
polarizador y ese ambiente polarizador
nos impide entender las cosas que están
pasando las cosas que han dejado de
pasar y las nuevas posibilidades que se
abren porque es que implementar un
acuerdo de paz no es sólo hacer una
tarea de una lista de mercado que ya se
escribió sino significa hacer nuevos
desarrollos qué es lo que creo que el
próximo gobierno tiene que entender con
más creatividad y originalidad que el
presente y hay que destacar que pese a
que este gobierno de turno en colombia
como usted lo dice a sergio no apoyaba
apoya este acuerdo de paz la comunidad
internacional sigue dándole el soporte a
este gobierno para que lo siga
implementando entonces hay confianza
también en que el gobierno puede avanzar
a su ritmo a su forma pero avanzar en
las tareas que tienen que hacer con este
acuerdo de paz firmado con la ex
guerrilla de las farc me queda el último
tema de la agenda y es el paso del
huracán yo está por el archipiélago de
san andrés en el caribe colombiano y lo
traigo a la mesa de debate porque
nuevamente aquí el gobierno colombiano
quedó en evidencia ante la falta de
prevención en momentos como estos este
tipo de catástrofes naturales y la isla
fue sumamente este archipiélago fue
sumamente afectado a cerca del 80 por
ciento de la infraestructura fue
destruida dos personas fallecieron y hay
que hacer una reconstrucción a todo
nivel de esta de esta zona insular
colombiana cuando otros países de
centroamérica se prepararon para la
llegada de este huracán colombia
simplemente emitió una alerta de
navegación para los pescadores y pues
las consecuencias son son grandes adrián
a
volvemos entonces con este tema y esta
falta de prevención de las instituciones
de emergencia colombiana que son
reactivas el gobierno reacciona cuando
ya el daño llegó cuando ya el huracán
pasó cuando ya destruyó y podía haber
hecho por lo menos una evacuación
controlada de personas vulnerables o de
personas enfermas o en condiciones de
vulnerabilidad allí en el archipiélago
de haberles dado una atención más
especial
sí señor bueno primero pues pensemos en
que los desastres naturales no son
ocasionados por la naturaleza sino por
la forma como nos relacionamos los
humanos con esa naturaleza eso implica
el reconocer todo el territorio todo el
contexto y las distintas relaciones y
significados que tienen las comunidades
frente a ese territorio en nuestra
política de atención y gestión de
riesgos de desastres también tiene un
componente de prevención pero hay que
decir que es el más
precario de los componentes de la misma
política este componente se supone que
debería estar incluyendo a los
ciudadanos para generar estrategias de
posibles redes de atención entre los
mismos ciudadanos de un territorio de
identificación de riesgos el
conocimiento ve el riesgo del territorio
y en caso ya de un desastre pues la
atención por supuesto a dos elementos al
respecto lo primero no tenemos
conciencia suficiente sobre las nuevas
formas en que nos estamos relacionando
con nuestro territorio cindy con la
manera como hemos dañado el mismo
territorio que hace que haya más
desastres el segundo continuamos
pensando sólo en lo urbano y en el
interior y san andrés desafortunadamente
ni toda la costa del país ni el
occidente y el sur hacen parte de esa
idea de centralidad si sergio
rápidamente me queda un minuto su
impresión sobre este tema
don santiago yo no soy experto en este
tema ni pretendo serlo simplemente diría
que cuando uno mira la historia reciente
de colombia ve una serie de
acontecimientos muy dolorosos como estos
que se vienen repitiendo teme mocoa el
tema gramalote las las inundaciones
derivadas de la crisis ambiental de
invernal y lo que creo es que eso
muestra que nos falta todavía mucho
desarrollo institucional para prevenir y
para atender de una manera mucho más
sostenible este tipo de asuntos pues
adrián a otálora de a sergio guarín
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en este especial del debate de
france 24 sobre las noticias destacadas
a lo largo del 2020 en el colombia a
ustedes muchas gracias por su sintonía
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales siga con
nuestra programación
[Música]